[Music]
in this video today we will shift again
to the pacific rim universe
and in this one we shall take an
in-depth look at one of the most
powerful monsters of the franchise from
pacific rim the black
the anime one that might even be more
powerful than any other kaiju or jaeger
this is the apex drone kaiju hybrid
which was created as a result of the
feedback loop
during uprising that killed off all the
other drone jaegers
and somehow this one survived and gained
independence from the precursors and
their commands
it was seen in the middle episodes as a
vague silhouette hunting for food
and would eat both humans natural world
animals and kaiju as well
so let's get down with this sickness
apex was as tall as the other drone
kaiju hybrids which would put him around
270 feet tall
it was initially white in color and
after the infestation of the kaiju brain
it would have been blue something like a
blue kaiju organic matter growing out of
many places in his body but after the
destruction of every other hybrid
the creature changed color to red
instead of blue and becomes
darker in shade as well there were
larger spikes that grew out from its
back
and arms and also had tiger stripes all
over its body
but red in color it also has two red
glowing eyes and a couple of sets of
metallic razor sharp teen in its mouth
it would have developed a digestive
system and a respiratory system as well
as time progresses since it was killing
and hunting kaiju
like the other drone jaegers apex is
biomechanical in design
built using kaiju blood and a kaiju
secondary brain built within
a quantum data co while its kaiju nature
was initially concealed with the
structure of a jaeger
the activation of its secondary brain
forces its organic nature outside its
chassis
it can create breaches independent of
the precursors and form neural bridges
with living organisms but unique to the
drone jagers and kaiju apex can
act outside the parameters of the
precursor's hive mine
on its own apex uses the isolated
continent of australia as a personal
hunting ground
feeding off of other kaiju it kills apex
is house time towards any and all life
it considers a threat
to its existence but will cooperate with
others if it chooses to do so
well these drone created hybrids are
outfitted with missiles and other
traditional weaponry designed for
jaegers
additionally they were built with energy
cores that can generate enough power to
recreate
the bridge that connects earth to the
antiverse while grown hybrids can be
controlled remotely the secondary brain
the secondary kaiju brain embedded in
its design allows the drones to override
their human control by command
as well as the precursor's command in
the case of apex
and like naturally manufactured kaiju
hybrids operate within the hivemind
system of the precursors
sharing information through a connection
similar to the drift
well the feedback loop that killed
almost all of them except for apex was a
way to block newton's signals which
means the precursor signals
to control them and then reversing them
back into the kaiju brain
which grows in intensity every time the
signal finishes a cycle
and hence like a chain reaction becomes
stronger and stronger and ends up in the
kaiju brain
exploding however the apex creature
managed somehow
to survive the attack it might have been
able to do so by breaking the loop
before it became too powerful
or there was a glitch in the system of
the kaiju hybrid and it broke the loop
whatever the case may be the apex kaiju
drone hybrid emerged out of this in a
singular mine
and not connected to the hive mine of
the precursors anymore
it was able to break free and carry no
allegiance whatsoever to any side in the
war
after the uprising kaiju war apex began
attacking both sides alike
and its rampage extends into meridian
city as the kaiju begins to overrun
australia well while in meridian city it
detects a human kaiju hybrid
in the basement of the ppdc recruitment
center and tries to establish a neural
bridge with it
but fails and after meridian city falls
during operation blackout
apex roams the ruined city and australia
picking off
canine kaiju that hunts in the area
during one of its hunts
it inadvertently saves taylor and haley
the protagonist from sudden death
but tries to eat them next it later
responds to the sound of haley calling
for help
and goes after the canine kaiju that
also called
rippers and it goes after them again
later in the series in the boneyard
scenes it engages
a category 3 kaiju called acid quill and
attacks atlas destroy as well apex is
then halted by the kaiju boy
accompanying the travis siblings and it
recognizing this child
as the hybrid it attempted to drift with
before apex and the boy forms a bond
the two shared their memories in the
drift before linking with haley to
validate the boy's story
which convinces apex to cease all
hostile actions against atlas destroyer
as a parting token it gives the travel
siblings
the arm of chaos nemesis before moving
on to consume the corpse of acid quill
this shows that the creature is sentient
and only attacks for survival
it initially did not want to attack
atlas destroyer but was forced into the
fight
because the two protagonists thought it
was gonna kill the boy and so with that
we come to the end of this video
do like for support subscribe to be a
part of this mind cue family
and also smash that notification bell
for regular updates when we post new
videos
on monsters specific rim kaiju's
creatures
godzilla vs condescension videos and
more right here on minecube
take care fam